في نهاية هذا الفيديو ،
سنمنحك اختيار المكان الذي تريد
السفر إليه ، هل أنت رفيق أحمق ، ما زلنا
في حالة إغلاق ، لا لا لا لا ، ليس في الحياة الواقعية ،
لكننا سنعطيك أنت
وأربعة  روابط مختلفة لأربعة
خيارات مختلفة حتى تتمكن من متابعة
القصة ويمكنك النقر فوق
أيهما تريد ثم تحديد المكان الذي
تريد الذهاب إليه ، فهذا جيد جدًا ، بالتأكيد
حسنًا ، دعنا
نتذكر هذا عندما يمكننا السفر في كل مكان
يتذكر العالم
عندما كان بإمكاننا القيام
بأشياء عادية مثل الذهاب إلى الحانة ، أفتقدها
الآن ، قد أعرف ولكن ربما لا نحتاج إلى
تذاكر طيران حفنة من النقود
وعالم خالٍ من الأوبئة للذهاب في مغامرة
مرحبًا بها في miniatur wunderland أوه
هذا عالم مليء بالاحتمالات ، إنه
عالم صغير حقًا ، لذا
بدأ كل شيء منذ ما يقرب من 20 عامًا قبل
شقيقي الأكبر سناً الذين توصلوا إلى
الكثير من الأفكار المجنونة جدًا وكان أحدهم
هو بناء أكبر نموذج في العالم بعيدًا
نحن فيه  هامبورغ، ألمانيا  ومرحبًا بكم في
هذا العالم النموذجي المترامي الأطراف وهو
ما نحتاجه تمامًا لعالم من الأماكن التي
نتمنى جميعًا أن نتمكن من زيارة عالم مليء
بالحياة جيدًا ، وسأدع سيباستيان
يعطيك تفاصيل التصميم بالكامل حوالي
1500 متر مربع وكل شيء
متصل بالسكك الحديدية ، لذلك لدينا 16
كيلومترًا من السكة ونحو 1000
قطار يمر عبر 1 بضع مئات من
السيارات التي يتحكم فيها الكمبيوتر.
العالم
[الموسيقى]
إنه مجرد شيء مثل حكاية خرافية ،
أرض العجائب الصغيرة تحمل الرقم
القياسي العالمي لأكبر نموذج للسكك الحديدية ولكن
لديها أيضًا رقم قياسي آخر ، نعم ،
هذه الموسيقى تتجه نحو
شيء مذهل شديد البرودة
ومحير للعقل هو أسوأ
شخصيتي  أبرز ما في هو المطار الذي يحتوي على
42 طائرة يتحكمون في الكمبيوتر
ويمكنهم الإقلاع والهبوط ولكنهم استغرقوا 4
ملايين يورو وخمس سنوات من المبنى
I لكل  أحب أن أكون في
المطار ويمكنني غسل جميع الطائرات
لساعات ، فهذه هي غرفة التحكم الخاصة بنا الموجودة
في قلب بلاد العجائب
إذا قمنا بتدريب كل سيارة ، يتم
التحكم في كل رحلة من هنا في الوقت
المناسب لتختار المكان الذي تريده  اذهب ،
لديك أربعة خيارات ، اختر جيدًا ، آمل أن
تختار بشكل صحيح ، سأذهب إلى
مدينة سين بنفسي ، أعتقد أنني أستحق أن أكون
هناك بعد الوقوف أمام
الكاميرا مثل هذا وأبدو وكأنه
أداة مطلقة لالتقاط الجليد بشكل جيد
[موسيقى]